the way the folks have done things here
for thousands years works the in you
pack figured out 10,000 years ago just
what materials are best for what
particular use at what particular time
of year and we just followed that
pattern wolf wolf wolf earning like hell
there are real fast animals and so when
you get an opportunity after just take
the shot and try to make my shots come I
think I got it
my mom taught me how to free the souls
of hunters animals that punky act the
free their soul and just pretty much cut
their throat so their spirit can be
lifted and go try again it's pretty much
respect for the animal I'm gonna cut it
the way I wanted for my dachshund roughs
the traditional style the teeth and
stuff they make pretty charms
we thank the wolf for the kindness of
taking his skin I'm gonna make use of
what this guy is the fur is a necessary
survival item and that's really
important up here especially a 40 50
below we are going mammoth tusk hunting
this is the time of the year where you
can actually walk down the beach and
find things like um ten thousand dollar
piece of tusks or
a real nice tooth we call it scouting
we're looking for nice chunks of wood
nice pieces of bone anything that we can
make artwork out of mom they got a piece
of mammoth over here we're looking at a
bull test here mammoth ivory is um is
beyond 1971 and since she's uh they're
both members of the corporation that
owns this land this is their land too
that's what we're looking for I take my
time and I put like a month into
something like this and then I just get
real detail and make it to a person
standing up for something and then on
grand grand and then when something hit
dude knows like mammoth only the native
people can do this hunt so I've chosen
my son John and my oldest daughter King
Mack and they'll be joining done we
started off chasing a new group and we
caught on to this one it's a nice little
ring seal this is the seal we just got
back with from our seal hunt we want to
try to keep the meat with the meat and
keep the oil with the oil now that we're
done cutting up all the blubber and
making tiny strips like this all we do
is uh put this in the porch by the next
couple days it should be from blubber to
oil and then we'll be able to put the
back feet together giant into the bucket
of oil
and then that would preserve it
throughout be someone when we render
down the blubber we use it as our oil
when we dip our frozen foods or our
dried foods in and that's usually a real
delicacy and it gives us energy so um
pretty much everything goes with seal
oil up here